>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Nancy Groce: Hello.
My name is Nancy Groce.
I'm a folklorist at the American
Folklife Center here at the Library
of Congress, and I'd like to welcome
you to the latest presentation
on our ongoing Benjamin
A. Botkin Lecture Series.
The Botkin Series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
discipline of folklore,
ethnomusicology, oral history
and cultural heritage while
enhancing the collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
For the Center and the Library,
the Botkin Lecture has
formed an important facet
of acquisition activities.
Each lecture is videotaped
and becomes part
of a permanent collection.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcasts
on the Library's website where
they are available for viewing
to Internet patrons
throughout the world.
So, if you haven't already done
so, now would be an excellent time
to turn off any electronic
devices you have with you.
Very often the American
Folklife Center partners
with other divisions here at
the Library of Congress to put
on lectures and concerts, and
today I am delighted to say
that this event is
being co-sponsored
by the John W. Kluge Center, and
I want to thank the Kluge Center
for their help and
support in this project.
One of the great joys as working as
a folklorist is the enormous scope
of topics that folklorists
are encouraged to study.
Although folklorists might be better
known for their research in music
and legends, myths and
customs and material culture,
many folklorists are also
involved in setting traditions
and practices surrounding food,
food preparation and preservation
and the use of food in
rituals and celebration.
The American Folklife Center
archive contains an enormous amount
of materials about food and
food-related traditions,
and I welcome you all to come
and do research in our holdings.
Today I have the pleasure
of introducing folklorist Danille
Elise Christensen, who the last year
or so as a Kluge Fellow has
been here at the Library
and using the resources of the
American Folklife Center as well
as a holdings of numerous other
divisions to study [no audio]
which will be addressed
in today's talk.
Dr. Christensen received her PhD
in Folklore from Indiana University
and is an assistant [no
audio] Virginia Tech.
Her work focuses on ways people
shape everyday speech, actions
and the objects they seek to
influence and persuade others.
She's especially interested in
gendered domestic labor as a side
of commentary and display.
In 2015, she was awarded the
prestigious John W. Kluge Fellowship
by the Library of Congress and
she's presently completing her book,
"Freedom from Want: Home Canning
in the American Imagination,"
which is based on her Kluge project.
Today, she'll be speaking on home
canning, cultural narratives,
technological change and the
status of traditional knowledge.
I'd ask you to join me in
welcoming her: Dr. Christensen.
[ Applause ]
>> Danille Christensen: Hello,
it's good to see so many friends
out there, and thank you for giving
up your lunch hour, and I apologize
in advance for talking about
food during the lunch hour
that you're giving up.
[Laughter] My topic
today is home canning.
That is the preserving of heat
sterilized fruit, vegetables
and meat in sealed containers.
I'm interested in the technologies
involved, in the artifacts
and processes that turn perishable
matter into stuff that can be stored
and exchanged according
to human desires,
but I want to also know how
technology -- excuse me --
I want to know how technologies
themselves in the societies
in which they are apart
are shaped by talk.
So, in a moment, I'm going to
share some of the narratives
that circle around home canning.
What kinds of values and agendas has
canning been connected with and how?
Who is telling these
stories and why?
What kinds of power
relationships emerge?
Are there good guys and bad guys?
And how do changes in technology
and other material context affect
how these stories play out?
I'll spend some time sharing an
overview of cultural narratives
that emerge in materials
from the Library of Congress,
and then I'll shift into two
narratives about progress
and authoritative knowledge that
tend to erase women's roles.
First though let me share
my appreciation for everyone
who has made my time here at the
Library of Congress so amazing.
I've been here since February and,
unfortunately, I am headed back
to Blacksburg in 2 weeks.
I'm glad to be going back
to Blacksburg but sad
to be leaving the Library.
So to my Kluge colleagues who
are still in the United States
and made the trek over from our
offices in the Jefferson Building,
thanks for the conversation,
commiseration and willingness
to act excited over small
scholarly breakthroughs.
The Kluge staff also have my
gratitude for their support,
problem solving, ability to
procure European chocolate
and general good will.
[Laughter] Nancy Groce and others
at the American Folklife
Center did the leg work
for this Botkin Lecture,
which is one small part
of the regular programming.
My current work in
progress, as Nancy mentioned,
is a book called "Freedom From Want:
Home Canning in the
American Imagination,"
and it got its start here at
the Library of Congress in 2012
when I was privileged to
receive a Parsons Fellowship.
During the two summers I
spent doing concentrated work
in the American Folklife Center
reading room, I read field notes,
examined photographs and transcribed
interviews about food preservation
in the mountains of North
Carolina and Virginia
and West Virginia's Coal River
Valley, on ranches in Nevada,
and among immigrant families
in the American West.
My folklore colleagues here at the
Library offered invaluable help
and encouragement over those years
and the collections themselves
helped me understand how home
bottling traditions fit into a
matrix of preservation activities.
The Blue Ridge and Coal River
collections, for example,
demonstrate a range of
dehydration practices that continue
because they make sense in terms
of local tastes, social structures,
built environments and
values, such as reluctance
to be completely dependent
on electricity.
So there's J.A. Easter
and his technology.
Here's Carrie Severt .
Her, this image and her
interviews and things
in the collection demonstrate how
some technologies are dependent
on others such as her drying
rack and wood stove combination.
The drying rack is not too
useful without the stove.
And I don't have a photo of
anyone using a car dashboard
as a drying rack, but that's another
strategy that's very efficient.
Here's Maisy Beamer
of Galax, Virginia,
who noted that people dry
food on glass in the sun
if they don't have space inside.
A roof she said will dry food
in a hurry when it's a hot day.
In fact, she had gotten tired
of eating the fresh beans
in her refrigerator
and put some out to dry
on her cellar roof the day
folklorist Jerry Johnson stopped
to talk with her.
And I'll be showing lots
of photographs today.
I spent at last two months in prints
and photographs and then two months
in Folklife and so I
wanted to showcase some
of the really great
resources that we have here.
Here's one last photo
from the AFC collections.
This is from the Coal River Project.
Here is an example of "leather
britches beans" strung on thread
and hung from porch
beams or rafters.
The pods take four or five days
to dry outside unless
it is rainy or damp.
When the weather turns, you've
got to bring them inside.
The drying beans look pretty
in rafters and porch railings.
Like chili ristras in New Mexico
strung leather britches act
as a visual symbol of shared culture
within Appalachian communities.
I also spent a lot
of time, as I said.
in Prints and Photographs.
The staff there took me hostage for
two months always finding new things
for me to look at, and I'm
really grateful, thank you.
I see you in the back row.
You'll see plenty of examples
throughout the presentation,
and I did finally make it to
Rare Books and Manuscripts,
so thanks to Michael North, Maphon
Ashman, Stephanie and others
who helped me track down the books
I needed including this book,
Ann Mary Dutton's book from 1800.
In 18th Century and 19th
Century English language sources,
they make clear distinctions
between the words "to preserve,"
which means to use sugar, right?
"To pickle," which means to
use a salt brine or vinegar.
And "to keep," which means to
maintain for a relatively long time
and relative means like
until Christmas or all winter
or the next year without the use
of a taste-altering preservative.
So that distinction and we often
think about as being just part
of contemporary canning where you
don't add sugar and things, right?
You can find it in these
older books as well.
This so called "cold water method"
to keep barberries that's up here,
that was still being advocated
in 1919 to preserve rhubarb,
cranberries, gooseberries and sour
cherries although the 1919 author,
Olive Hayes, noted in italics that,
"this method is not
always successful
as the acid content varies with
the ripeness and the locality
in which the fruits are grown."
I'll come back to her concern
with context a little bit later.
Also in Rare Books, I found this
British bill-of-fare published
in 1708 which called for February
meals that included peas, asparagus,
strawberries and cream,
several apple pies,
raspberry cream and
gooseberry tarts.
Some of the fruit had probably
been over-wintered in cool cellars
or forced early in greenhouses.
The menus were created
by Henry Howard,
who was a well-regarded
chef employed
by several members of aristocracy.
So he would have had
access to hot houses,
but the gooseberry tarts were
possible because at least
by the late 1680s people knew
how to store firm, whole, firm,
acidic fruits including
gooseberries, currants, cherries,
bases and damsons in
sealed bottles and jars.
And basses and damsons like
plums belong to the genus prunus
but are smaller, drier and tarter
than their sweet, meaty cousins.
This book, which included the
menus, was first published in 1703.
By 1726 the book had gone
into a fifth printing.
A recipe Howard calls "to keep
gooseberries" appeared unchanged
in the second edition and fifth
printing and exactly as it appears
in the original 1703 book as well.
As you'll see, the recipe relies on
two, the two procedures fundamental
to what we now call canning.
First, existing detrimental yeast,
mold and bacteria are killed
or retarded through the
application of heat.
And second, further
contamination is minimized
by sealing the container,
by stopping [inaudible].
Notice that he actually calls
for clarified mutton fat
to be used to seal the damsons.
And what's interesting, so, in
the preface to this book he talks
about the different kind
of manuscript sources
that these come from.
All right, so finally, I'm indebted
to Allison Kelly and Connie Carter
in the Library Science
Technology and Business Division,
who have loaned me their
personal books, offered me snacks
and sent me relevant materials
over the past four years.
And actually the other day Connie
just gave me this replica Ball Jar,
so I brought it to show you.
In the stacks, I discovered more
than I thought I needed to know
about 19th Century
technologies like this wax sealer.
And I also learned how fluid food
preservation processes in terms
for the turn of the century.
So, at the Third Annual
Lake Placid Conference
on Home Economics this
is Mrs. Melvil Dewey.
Annie Dewey who was the
wife of Melvil Dewey
of Dewey Decimal fame, right?
And so she is setting out
sort of a schema of how
to organize preservation.
She's actually part of a
larger home economic section
of the Dewey Decimal System.
And I have found recipes for
preserving food with borax.
So that's not a mistake,
but the organizational scheme is a
little fuzzy to me here, you know,
boiling and sterilization can
overlap so there's sort of coming
to clarify those terms,
I guess, for themselves.
I also accumulated a
lot of food safety texts
and food science and technology.
And so I think this is as
good a time as any to go
over a few food safety
principles that would be useful
in understanding the rest of
the conversation today, right?
So, first you need to kill
or disable existing microbes.
You can do that through
sterilization,
high temps over sufficient
enough time.
You can also add sugar
or salt or acid
or you can dehydrate
things for desiccation.
Once you have sort of
disabled the microbes,
you need to keep the
microbes out so you need
to have some sort of a seal, right?
So that's sort of the base of
parameters we're working within.
And you can see that in this
1876 set of instructions
where you take cold fruit and
put hot syrup and put into a jar
and place the open jar in a
boiler lined with a grate, pebbles
and straw to sort of
protect it from breakage.
You fill it up with water to the
neck, you cover the boiler and boil
for a specific amount of time
depending on what you're cooking.
You remove it and let the
jar stand for five minutes
and then you add a rubber ring and a
cap and screw it down with a wrench
because this is a zinc cap that you
have to really put a lot of effort
in to getting it down there, but you
can see this is a little problematic
because it doesn't add the seal
until after the sterilization
has already processed, right?
So you've got a chance for
contamination to occur.
So, again, you need to
it in that order, right?
First you sort of cover
it, you sterilize it,
and then you make sure
that it's sealed.
Air tight.
Okay. So the last acknowledgement I
want to give is to Benjamin Botkin
for whom this lecture
series is named.
He is shown here in this Victory
Garden during World War II.
Botkin championed the notion
that vernacular expressive culture
is always relevant to contemporary,
social and political life.
The pattern of things people say,
do and make in everyday life are
not merely practical or decorative,
but in fact, they shape
structures of power.
And home canning is a case in point.
Shelf stable canned goods have been
a part of everyday American life
since the mid-19th Century.
Where industrial canning utilized
metal tins and mechanized processes,
other forms of canning came
to rely on glass bottles
and the domestic labor of women.
I should reiterate that in the
United States home canning has come
to refer almost exclusively
to preserving fruit
and vegetables in air tight jars.
In the literature, it's not
unusual to hear people talk
about glass cans, right, when
they're referring to jars.
Of course the job has not
fallen exclusively to women.
So here you see this couple
from New Mexico working
on currants and apricots.
That said, the story of
canning is complicated, right?
Even in the early 1900s the
practice had multiple meanings.
For some, home canning was
old-fashioned, inefficient
or embarrassing already
by like the early 1900s.
For others is a valuable skill
to be displayed in public
and mobilized in times of need.
In today's context of economic
instability, automated systems
and cultural and environmental
change,
do- it-yourself canning
is experiencing a revival.
More people are canning
their own food.
The process can be a way to
recall people and places;
to confirm authentic or esoteric
taste; and to enact abstract values
such as stewardship
or self-sufficiency.
That is a vernacular process
like canning becomes instrumental
in articulating and further
materializing ideographs:
Those seemingly self-evident
words and phrases that,
"function as guides,
warrants, reasons or excuses
for behavior and belief".
And that's Michael McGee.
These one term sums of an
orientation include things
like tradition, heritage,
authenticity, art, identity,
but also a number of
key words and code words
that index broader cultural
narratives and ideologies.
I'll show you a few examples.
So, one cultural narrative
or sort of ideograph
that indexes these larger
cultural narratives is creativity.
These images, one from 2011
and the other from the 1940s,
demonstrate how canning can be
an expressive creative practice;
not merely a practical one.
People often think of canning in
the past as people just did it
because they had to but we do
it now because we choose to,
but that's not an accurate depiction
of what, from what I have found
of people's motivations for canning.
Beauty has always been something
that people have been
interested in and sought after.
I'm going to show you a
range of photos that sort
of emphasize how home canning
can be a sign of display.
So here you have Mrs. Frank Jacobs,
who is carefully placing pears
in a jar and that has a
practical effect of making sure
that you got it closed
in efficient pack, right?
It seems to be floating up.
But it's also aesthetically pleasing
especially in terms of evenness
and regularity, which is often
valued by people who can.
Here's another sort of
sense of canning as display.
You can't see the sign very well
right here, but it's actually sort
of a call for people
to contribute exhibits,
sort of a rotating exhibit.
Each of these has the name
of the woman who made it.
Some of them I have been able
to read with magnification,
but this display is
interesting in that it sort
of brings together
national security--
which I'll get to in a
moment because it's part
of a World War I era display--
but it's also a chance in
this public venue, right,
the Library for women to
display their handiwork.
And here we have the
Gonzales County Fair.
I should say that display is not
incidental among many canners.
It may actually affect the
procedures that they employ.
One Illinois bacteriologist noted
in 1935 that taste, texture,
color and arrangement of jarred
foods are one thing when it comes
to earning social recognition
at the county fair,
but concern about public health
risks should trump other performance
agendas, he thought.
He railed against housewives
and their ill-informed teachers
who use unsafe procedures
in the name of display.
Numerous books, he observed,
caution that "temperatures higher
than boiling tend to
injure the delicate color
and texture of most fruits".
In an attempt to preserve flavor
and yet address growing awareness
of microscopic threats, in the early
1900s some canners experimented
with sterilization process in
which food was heated several times
but at temperatures below boiling.
And this is also a similar process
was actually promoted by the USDA
in the teens: the intermittent
method
as a way to sort of kill off...
The idea was that spores might
not germinate the first day
but if you waited another
day then they would germinate
and then you could boil them
again and kill that, right?
In 1932, well, actually in 1913,
three students at Stanford died
because they ate food
using this method.
So it does have some risks.
Here's another sort of version
of canning as a site for display.
This is from the 1960s and
it's part of a concerted effort
to make canning appealing to younger
women and what's really interesting
in this is that it says, "Can't
you just see yourself praised,
admired, envied, appreciated?"
and it goes through each
of these different sort
of potential audiences
this young woman might have
and shows how canning could
help her win some social status.
Another sort of ideograph
or narrative
that indexes this idea
of abundance, right?
So here we're back
at this other image.
Because it was produced
by the Office
of War Information during World
War II, it's also concerned
with abundance and it actually sort
of steps out of display conventions
that many home canners
have when they're not--
this is posed by a
photographer, right?
So, often these will be
arranged according to sort
of color and type of food, right?
And these are sort of mismatched,
but they show the variety
of different kinds of
foods from potatoes
to beets and peas, greens, right?
That's available, that
can be available
to families during wartime.
Sometimes I have been overwhelmed
by the abundance that I have seen
in the FSA and OWI files.
This family is actually the Doc
and Julia Miller Family
near White Plains, Georgia.
They have eight kids,
four teenagers.
There is a lot of variety in the
kinds of foods that are in display,
but I have to wonder how
they got all that food
out in the middle of
the yard, right?
I mean here's sort of
another view and all the times
when Farm Security
Administration photographers were
in some ways documenting the
results of funds that had been given
to families as part of various
recovery programs, and I'm afraid
that at times it was
inconvenient for them to display,
but it is an impressive show.
Here we see a narrative
of self-sufficiency.
The idea that you can pull
yourself up by your bootstraps,
but you might need a
little help along the way.
So, on this one side, it says "John
was not getting the right kind
of food, no garden, no cow,
no canned stuff for winter.
Thousands of farm families are sick
because they do not
grow their own food."
The other side John two years later
after his family started
the Live at Home farming.
"Plenty to eat, the
right things to eat.
The families have learned to grow
their own good health" and script
"through Farm Security's
Program of Live at Home Farming."
Okay and these exact same images
were used for another panel
that was called "They need
our help to help themselves".
Okay, so sort of posing
a choice that's available
to the individual and
also to the society.
Another thing that you'll
see is economic security.
Actually if you think about
it, canning is a practice
that enacts a nation's
dominant economic system, right?
It is a literal accumulation
of capital stored
up to enable future
productive capacity.
Another theme is National Security
both in terms of food produced
at home and abroad
so that [inaudible] food will
win the war and write the peace.
But also here you see
it as a metaphor
for geo-political containment,
all right, of the Kaiser.
And the National Security images
seemed to inspire lots of moments
of levity, at least given
canning's tremendous pun potential.
So, here we have women
from Summit, New Jersey,
dressed in food conservation
uniforms ready for a parade
to promote Hoover's voluntary
Food Conservation Plan, right?
There wasn't mandatory
rationing in World War I.
So there's a parade and they
made these signs that say Work
or Waste, Can a Can for Uncle Sam.
Canner Collapse.
Preserve or Perish is another
one that's not up here, right?
So they've got their placards,
they've got their uniforms,
they're ready to go.
I also found through various
youth groups including 4-H
and Red Cross groups and food
conservation groups who got together
and they would have these
songs that they sing.
So if anyone wants to sing
this, it's to the tune
of "O'Maryland" or "O Tannenbaum."
I will give you this
jar of raspberry jam
that I made earlier this summer.
[Laughter] Any takers?
Basically...
[inaudible].
So this last part is: [sings]
"Our garden truck we here preserve
/ Our food supply we now conserve /
And so democracy we serve /
Right here in Thompson Center."
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
And I believe Thompson Center is
here close by in Maryland, right?
Okay, we also have other puns here.
We have Elise Borden
and her calf, Beulah,
and with help of Elmer
the bull in bringing
in tomatoes from the garden.
Notice that they're using older
called "lightning style jars"
with the glass lid and wire bail
perhaps because of war shortages
of metal but also for
nostalgic value.
And so we see this idea of
preserving the American way
and encoded in that sort of
notion of the American way
that you see here, is a
division of labor based in gender
and there's a strikingly similar
New Yorker cover by Helen Hokinson
that also illustrates
division of labor based
in class and race as well.
So, canning along with
other domestic tasks
and skills was also used as a tool
of assimilation and/or became a mark
of acculturation on
American Indian Reservations
and in boarding schools especially
at the turn of the Century.
So this idea of a particular kind
of domesticity is also
related to canning.
And this is a group
that's gathered to learn
about pressure cookers in Oklahoma.
The woman in the middle as
far as I can identify her
in her 60s is Lydia Humanstriker
[phonetic] who was a school teacher
and married to a local judge.
The four boys in front were 4-H boys
who had to gather wood for the fire,
but this canning is
also sort of a source
of pride and connection, right?
About how preserving strategies
sync with indigenous fruit planting
and harvesting traditions.
So, this display of I can't
tell exactly but I imagine
at least some of those are peaches.
It would make sense because of the
orchards that Diné people had tended
for hundreds of years and then
we also here's another image
by Virginia Stroud that is
referring to gathering cactus fruit
and berries as has been practiced
in many parts of the United States.
And then finally here is another
form of sort of connection, right?
We have a celebrity
with common roots.
This post on Loretta Lynne's
official Facebook page was shared
almost 3,000 times and liked by more
than 30,000 people in
less than 24 hours.
And it elicited thousands of
really fascinating comments.
So that's just a quick rundown of
some of the cultural narratives
that canning plays a role in that
gives a sense of the discursive
and ideological context that we're
talking about and the context
in which canning has
or does play a part.
So I'm going to switch gears a
little bit now because my thinking
about context has been
simulated in the last few months
by the book called "The
Mushroom at the End" of the World
by Anna Lowenhaupt Tsing.
The book's subject is the matsutake
mushroom, a much sought after fungus
that flourishes in the
wake of dissuption.
In Oregon, it loves living near
the large pole pines that emerge
after the ponderosas are gone.
In Japan, matsutake thrive in
forest soils scrapped clean
by peasant foresting.
This mushroom's life ways are
complex, always a-tuned to
and responding to other factors
in its immediate environment.
Matsutake's [inaudible] is out
of step with modern capitalism,
which is predicated on the ability
to scale up, to expand smoothly
in new spaces without having to
rethink its framing assumptions.
Scalability is achieved, she
writes, by minimizing encounter.
Monoculture plantations, for
instance, become infinitely scalable
by first wiping local context
clean by clear cutting forests,
concreting existing communities
and then importing cologne
[phonetic] sugar cane sort
of a plant life that's
oblivious to encounter
and coerced labor that's been
shorn of social relations
that could make a difference, right?
This plantation style alienation
where parts are infinitely
interchangeable and exchangeable
in the market can also been
seen in fast food franchises,
which seem so similar and
the workers so dispensable.
Blank slate ferments in the
food world are another example
of an attempt to make production
predictable by mitigating context.
In this case, makers of cheese, beer
or wine produce a consistent product
by first removing existing
organisms in the base liquid
and then re-inoculating
it with a pure culture
of the bacteria they
wish to do its work.
So I've been thinking about
scalability in relation to the ways
that home canning is
often coupled narratively
to fear and to compliance.
If you Google botulism, you
get pictures of Mason jars.
Botulism is a specter that
has haunted home bottling
since the early decades
of this century.
Not long ago when I attended
a high-end canning workshop,
traveling lecture Marisa
McClellan started her demonstration
where she always starts
by asking "who's afraid
of killing your whole family?"
[Laughter] She then explains
why the food she makes--
jams, jellies and chutneys is no
more dangerous than moldy bread.
"You can't kill anyone with
pickles," she told the crowd,
but people are still afraid.
And I should acknowledge here that
there are real health risks involved
in food processing and the deaths
from botulism earlier and especially
in the bottling of
vegetables and meat.
U- to-date canning guidelines
are important and I encourage you
to consult the National Center
for Home Food Preservation
at the University of Georgia
for more specific information
about current recommendations.
These nationwide guidelines are
intended to ensure safety for all,
regardless of specific context.
In the wake of botulism scares
of the 1920s, for instance,
government instructors were asked
to recommend only pressure
canning-- just to be safe.
So for everything.
Instruction books like
this Hazel Atlas Manual
from 1924 started telling their
readers to boil the contents
of every bottle of vegetables
and meat before consuming
it, just to be safe.
Context-free practices like these
that arguably define modern life
and notions of progress also do
violence to localized knowledge,
which is learned through lifetimes
of observation and practice
and developed within circumscribed
intertwined ecosystems.
In the case of home canning, I'm
going to focus on two examples
of metaphorical clear-cutting
in the name of progress.
First I'll explore how
the idea of invention
and discovery raised the complex
networks that actually give rise
to innovation and in this
case erroneously reduce women
to passive consumers of technology.
The histories of canning
that crop-up in everything
from food magazines to microbiology
textbooks invariably celebrate a
single father of canning,
Nicolas Appert.
You can see he's a hero
in France, as well, right?
He has his own stamp
and this is a park
with a statue that's devoted to him.
Further, Appert is depicted
as a scientist motivated
by military concerns and aligns
progress with the blank state
of a laboratory; a space positioned
in contrast to grandma's methods.
Second I'll consider
clostridium botulinum.
The bacteria whose spore
produces the botulism toxin--
an example of living complexity
not unlike the matusake.
When that emerges from and, indeed,
is created by the ruins
of the modern world.
Preconceive the complexity of
this microbe life makes me weary
of blaming traditional knowledge
when something breaks down.
The efficacy of some
local practices--
canning corn and tomatoes, for
instance, or sealing cooked sausage
and lard they are rendered
useless or even dangerous
by external factors
that include changes
in population mobility-so
people are moving to new places
with different altitudes
and climates;
by changes of environmental
conditions, food systems,
food technologies ; and even changes
in the chemistry of the food itself,
but these practices and the people
who do them experience another blow
and they are then blamed for these
failures by being characterized
as backwards, sloppy, habit
driven or simply ignorant
when existing systems break down.
And I'm not saying that local
practice is inherently harmless.
For instance, I would not try to can
Vienna Sausages in the dishwasher,
which I have heard of
people trying to do.
[Laughter] So, let me just take
you through sort of this story
of home canning that
is often out there.
And I chose this one
because it's kind of fun.
It's from the brochure that
was handed out in my hometown
of Columbus, Ohio, in the 1950s.
And I found it at the National
Museum of American History.
Here's the story, right?
"Home canning was first started
by a great soldier and emperor."
They were losing men and I'll give
12,000 francs to any Frenchman
who finds a simple
way to preserve food.
So, Appert, you know,
drops everything.
He starts doing experiments.
He has some setbacks like
any good inventor does.
And then after 15 long years:
"You see, if food is sealed
from air it will keep
for a long time,
but different foods need
different recooking times."
"And made this time
chart for all foods?
Amazing!" "Finally in 1810..."
he receives the prize.
And "At the same time in England.
'You're seeing food in metal
canisters, Mr. Burant?"
(And that should be Durant.)
"Yes..., you might say I'm
canning food, might'en you?"
Canning became widespread by 1850
but no one knew why it worked,
but thankfully there was
Louis Pasteur and he figures
out that the bacteria
is the cause, right?
And heating kills them if
they're in a sealed container.
Then we jump to "The Mason
jar...invented 96 years ago," right,
and some different
versions of canning jars
and they claim today more
food is canned at home
in the combined output
of all canning factories.
I have not been able
to verify that claim.
In any case, this same
history has been repeated
in almost every history
of canning that you find.
In the magazine Lucky Peach,
in a film that is distributed
for science classes, for instance.
And this USDA website that was
recently launched does an excellent
job bringing together primary
resources and documents related
to the history of home canning, and
I encourage you to check it out.
It also depicts very effectively
what the dominant history
of canning looks like
in these stories.
Okay, so you have this huge blank
before a pear comes on the scene.
Then you have this then nothing
until John Mason invents
the Mason jar in 1858
and then the Ball Corporation
comes in.
So, this sort of, a pear gets
lionized and actually James Collins,
who wrote sort of the history
that everybody goes back
to for the history of the
commercial canning industry,
he writes that "Nobody had
ever preserved fresh vegetables
or fruits before.
For ages, the world had known
only drying, salting and smoking
to keep meats, fish and a few
fruits from season to season,"
and he's actually publishing this
in a canning trade periodical
and asking for other commercial
canners to give him feedback
so that this will reflect
well on the canning industry.
So, this sort of story that he tells
is very similar to other histories
of food preservation
generally, right?
And it's a very gendered story.
So this undated poster-- perhaps
intended to grace the walls
of a mid-Century home ec classroom--
tells a heroic narrative in which
engineered cold replaces passive
heat as a way to arrest
for food decay.
"Food Preservation from Cave Man
to Kitchen" chronicles
technological advances that begin
with Egyptian slaves drying
fish in the sun and ends
with an aproned housewife
unwrapping steaks pulled
from the build-in chest
freeze in her modern kitchen.
In between our decades
of exploration experimentation
and conquest.
And you can see here this
is where, right here,
is where the Napoleon
a pear story comes in.
In most of this pictorial
history, women are bystanders
to the various forms of physical
and intellectual labor involved
in making food last except
for the final three
frames of the chronology.
Here they stand alone
with refrigerators
and freezers apparently
enjoying freedom from extra work,
but historian Susan Strasser and
Ruth Schwartz Cohen have long
since dispelled the notion
that new household gadgets,
fuels and processes actually
or automatically make
women's lives easier.
New technologies have often
simply created different work
so the full burden of work
on a single woman's shoulders
or removed compensatory satisfaction
such as soon as social interaction
or opportunities to
display skill and beauty.
The images in this poster
confirm these losses.
These liberated women, for instance,
are noticeably divorced from messy,
sensory stimuli and
human interaction.
A more recent source
also asserts that men
and their inventions
improve women's lives
but does so a bit more suddenly.
This 1975 canning guide
explains "Traditionally,
man has provided food and
woman has preserved it,
but traditions change
and roles switch.
In fact, the canning process
for preserving food was
discovered by a man..."
The next paragraph
describes Appert's experiments
at the behest of Napoleon.
Then it continues: "Appert's
discovery made life easier for women
who had come to preserve summer
harvest for winter nourishment.
And so home canning soon became a
family tradition with one generation
of women passing their special
canning secrets along to the next."
Like the food preservation poster
the Bernardin Manual reduces the
idea of liberation to
extra leisure time.
Appert made life easier for women,
but in addition unlike the
suffrage era Campbell's Soup ads
that Catherine Parkin has analyzed,
this 1975 manual coops
feminist discourses.
It raises the ideas of changing
gender roles, increased freedoms
and distinctive kinds of
knowledge but it does so in order
to reassert the authority of men.
That is even in regard to
women's work men did it first
and they did it more rationally.
So men discover and women
have secrets, right?
Even this purported special
knowledge is undermined
by the next section of the manual
which reveals just what
those canning secrets are.
Continual improvements in canning
technologies often rendered the
experiential knowledge
of women obsolete,
and grandma's knowledge
was presented
as dangerous, even life threatening.
So I just want to quickly show some
of the predecessors
that were out there.
There was an Italian Abbot who
in 1765 had done some experiments
with meat extracts in closed flasks,
but he didn't really apply that.
So James Collins, who wrote
the History of Canning,
thought that was sort of a lame.
If you can't apply it in
the commercial world, right,
it doesn't really count as a
discovery, but there's also
if you look at the manuscript
sources you can see that these sort
of food preservation processes
that don't involve sugar,
that involve heating and
sealing are happening.
This particular one uses an oven.
This is from the same
cookbook of Mary Mott.
This is another recipe
for gooseberries.
You can see that is quite close
to the one that was published
in 1703 that we saw earlier.
I'm going to compare these on a
graph because I don't have time
to read all of these, but
you can see they appear,
and most of these sources are from
Great Britain, but there are some
that are from the United States
especially in the 19th Century.
This one the very first page of
this book, right, you get a recipe
for preserving currants
and then there's also one,
there's another version right below.
Here's one from 1829 and this
one has four different recipes
for bottling fruit.
Okay, and so let me just
show you this graph of all
of these different recipes
based on place, ingredients.
You'll notice that hardly any
of them use liquid, right?
And hardly any of them use
sugar until you get into sort
of later in the mid-19th Century.
Almost all of them there are a
couple of that sort of bake things
in the oven, but the others
are all scalded in water.
They're all except for these two
are sealed before and they're sealed
after with some particular
kind of, with resin or pitch
or other kinds of things.
There's precautions to take
them from breakage, right?
And also sometimes they're supposed
to be for a particular duration.
Well, that sort of big takeaway
is that all of these, right,
that are going on people are sharing
with each other they're attributing
them to other women, right?
Before Thomas Additing in
England and Nicolas Appert
in France actually get patents on
these sorts of processes, okay.
So they are, this knowledge
is circulating and, in fact,
in 1814 there's a review
that basically says, oh,
you didn't discover this: In behalf
of our country we must observe
that unless they have forsaken
the example and precepts
of their ancestors, they
must, already be more
or less acquainted already with
the methods of Mr. Appert," right?
So there's this at least then
there's a sort of acknowledged
that this is a common process
that people are building from,
but it's been erased in
our histories since then.
Let me just go over briefly
some of the technological shifts
that were happening because they
explain why the climate is so sort
of confusing in terms of processing.
Over the course of the 19th and 20th
Centuries home canning technologies,
containers, closures, processing
equipment and processing techniques
and even raw foods themselves
underwent a series of small
but ultimately dramatic changes.
Here's a small sampling of closure
types that people tried at the end
of the 19th Century when
home bottling as opposed
to long-standing salt, sugar,
vinegar-based preservation
methods became more common.
These closures of [inaudible] and
wax or liquid lead or air pressure
or rubber rings or mechanical
pressure from wires or clamps
or a combination of all of
these just for good measure.
And then we have the
open kettle method.
People are using visual measures
in order to sort of figure
out what's happening and if
they need to re-boil something
or there's one example of one of
these recipes I showed you said,
okay, well, it's good if
you can keep it on the shelf
because then you can watch
to see if it starts bubbling
and when it starts bubbling,
you should take it off
and do something else, right?
So people are really
using sensory information
to evaluate what's happening
and the problem with botulism is
that it is not detectable in the
ways that people have been trained
to detect and manage
spoilage, right?
So, it's odorless and
it's tasteless and so
that presents all sorts
of difficulties.
What I found interesting is that
rather than being presented as sort
of ignorant or unaware
of what was going on,
when you look at the transcripts
of people who had been canning
for lifetimes, they'll often
express that they are very aware
of the kinds of things that
are recommended, right,
and they talk about the ways
that their own families have kind
of mediated or managed
those kinds of things.
So she's giving here
specific information
about how long she's processing
it and things like that.
I wanted to just close
today by talking about some
of our own contexts that
are changing, right?
So botulism is interesting and
that context always matters.
It matters through
what your altitude is,
it matters how much
fat is in your process.
It matters what kinds of sort
of temperature or humidity
that you're working with.
And so and all of these things
can sort of combine or intertwine.
Even now contexts are
changing in these.
So there is a FreshTECH Homemade
Automatic home canning system
that has been initiated, right?
It capitalizes on the social
value of sharing homemade food
and pitches itself as a solution
for busy household
perhaps for working moms.
In any case, they say
it's as easy as 1, 2, 3.
Literally you pick 1 out of 28
jam, jelly, pickle, tomato sauce
or salsa recipes, prepare 6 half
pint or 3 quart jars, load the jars,
push the button that corresponds
to your recipe and walk away.
As the online description declares,
this machine and it's 70-built
in safety features take "the
guess work" out of canning.
And there's a whole sort
of literature I could talk
to you about, the ways that
women's knowledge has been, sort of,
it has literally been described
as "guess work," right?
This kind of experimentation,
sensory investment
in what's going on.
Trial and error tends to
be dismissed as guess work.
And with this latest, this latest
invention of Ball there are canners
that are pushing back
against the latest
against the latest tool's
remove of guess work, right?
Comments on the website
make it clear
that most viewers dislike the
confines of this automated system.
Wanting the freedom to experiment
with recipes to can all types
of foods and to further
develop their own skills.
And some have pointed out that
the canner works on the logic
of fear suggesting that
they will finally be able
to can a safe product.
By playing on the risk of danger
and the allure of dependency
that have characterized much
discourse on domestic technology
in the last century,
Ball can sell a product
that is essentially an
electric water bath--
but not everyone is buying.
Contexts keep changing and
so will canning just...Not
that long ago Ball revealed that
because it's changed the composition
of the sealing compound boiling
lids is no longer necessary and is,
in fact, detrimental,
which caused a big outcry
because it's the one thing that's
changed in the last 7 years
in terms of canning, right?
So people got concerned.
And so what I hope that you'll be
thinking about today is a story
about how modernity, with spatial
mobility and its rapid changes
to work processes and
technological systems,
emphasis on receive knowledge, can
undercut knowledge based in place,
personal experience
and sensory perception.
The women and the materials I have
encountered are not, by in large,
sloppy, careless or unintelligent.
Instead they are working with
a complicated set of variables
that feel the ripples of seemingly
smaller unconnected actions.
Like the matsutake ecosystem.
It's also a story of how any
invention is really a network
of skills and gestures, but by
consolidating things in the figure
of a pear, a concrete person
with a particular method, right?
We can identify a point
of before and after.
Time moves forward then as
[inaudible] says marked by progress.
In reality, life is a messy
overlap of technologies, materials
and environmental context.
Each of us work within these systems
but because canning in systems is
so enmeshed in the physical
world, because in fact,
death is on the line,
these interconnections
become a bit more visible.
Perhaps it can help us think
more clearly about the roles
or everyday material worlds play an
acquiring, articulating, validating,
endorsing and affirming
expert status.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I'll be happy to take any
questions that anyone has.
>> Male audience member:
Could you maybe summarize some
of the mechanisms for
the shift from,
I think you call it grandma's
knowledge to this more industrial
or scientific language of canning?
I know you touched on them, but
what are some of the mechanisms
or causal factors that
drove that shift.
It wasn't just that
a pear showed up.
>> Danille Christensen:
Right, right.
Well, part of it I mean it leads
to, it links to the rise of...
so when sort of the laboratory and
science is valorized as the site
of authentic knowledge-- and
I could show you pictures
of these men sitting
around on the jam boards
and they're like evaluating the jam.
Then domestic science starts moving
from spaces that seemed less.
So a laboratory is a
space in which you're able
to isolate particular
variable, right?
It's the sort of blank slate in a
sense and things start to make sense
because you're only looking
at one particular thing
and you're bracketing
everything else out, right?
And so even in terms of, sort of,
uniforms that people start wearing
in domestic science classes, the
ways that domestic labs are sort
of set up as these sterile
environments, right?
In some ways it's a way
to try to adopt the power
of scientific discourse
for themselves.
It happens through schools,
it happens through club work
where kids are being taught,
you know, the scientific method.
I think there's a picture I have:
So this is a jam board, right,
of the USDA chemistry guys.
These are women who are using
sort of doing community canning
with a large steam cooker, right,
or boiling water bath
alongside the creek.
And here's another example
of sort of a canning class,
a demonstration that's taking
place outside on the playground.
Those are very different
from the laboratory
but you also have these
more rationalized spaces,
these community canning spaces
and here is a good example
of a canning club girl who is
part of a tomato canning club
in which the girls in the 19 teens
would do these experiments, right?
So she is doing, she is blocking
out that one variable of what kind
of fertilizer you're using
and they would write reports,
they earned their own money,
they were proud of being involved
in the scientific process.
So this is another mechanism
in which that kind of happens.
Then on the flip side you've
got popular magazines and things
that are downplaying
grandma's knowledge
as there's a really
great, let's see....
There's lots of displays of
people with pressure cookers
or pressure canners to show
that they know the right
and safe way to do it, right?
Here's some instructions.
But then you've got like these
images of grandma in which anybody
like these processes are so simple
that anybody can operate it.
There's actually, this is an
interesting source that I found.
I started out, I got to it
from Prints and Photographs,
but it basically says, you know,
"It's amazing how people can't read.
A cup of granulated sugar means
a cup of anything sweet..."
shows she's saying that long-time
practices of substitution
and flexibility, right, are no good.
And "A good recipe
is important, too.
Those wonderful old recipes
handed down from grandma work
for your mother but
only 'cause she'd...
experimented with them many times."
There "were probably frequent
failures blamed on the bad weather
or other insignificant factors.
It's much better to
reply on modern guides.
Most of them have been tested more
times than you'd care to count.
" So the logic here is
really screwy because it says
like your grandma's recipes worked
because they've been tried a lot
of times, but you should
really try these other recipes
that have been tried a lot of
times by different people, right?
Like the scientists versus your
grandma and the scientists win so.
Any other questions?
Yeah?
>>Male audience member: At some
time you showed us a timeline,
I think from a website
at the University of
[ Inaudible ]
where you noted at the beginning
there's not much happening,
but I was wondering
how does this relate
to the history canning
on an industrial scale?
>> Danille Christensen: I'm sorry.
Can you repeat the last part?
>>Male audience member: How
does that relate to the history
of canning on an industrial scale?
>> Danille Christensen:
An industrial scale.
The commercial canners trace
themselves back to Appert
and to Peter Durand [phonetic]
in England who basically--
one scholar argues that Durand took
Appert's patent and just wrote it
in English and also added other
stuff just for good measure
and sent it in and then it was
actually bought by another company,
who actually like who started
canning in tin using that patent.
>> Male audience member: Did it
take off quickly after discovery?
>> Danille Christensen:
Commercial canning, yes.
Uh-huh. Yep.
So in the United States by...
by at least 1825 there were
commercial canneries operating
in the United States.
Often the early ones canned fish
or other kinds of goods like that.
>>Stephen Winick: So
you showed some examples
of canning recipes
from the 17th Century.
I wonder how far back we can trace
the idea of heat sterilizing,
heat canning, they didn't
know they were sterilizing it,
but I know there are medieval
cookbooks, but I don't --
>> Danille Christensen: -- I
would be interested to know.
I haven't looked at any.
These are the earliest manuscripts,
manuscript books that I found
in Rare Books, but I
would love to know.
I'm sure it goes back
much farther, right?
Yeah.
>>Betsy Peterson: So when
is your book coming out?
>> Danille Christensen:
The manuscript is due
in March of this next year.
So probably it'll be a year
and a half or so-- I'm hoping.
[Laughter]
>> Female audience
member: Thank you so much.
I really wish I could sing
because I really want that jar.
[Laughter]
>> Danille Christensen:
It would have been better
than my singing I'm sure.
>> Female audience
member: No, really I can't.
It's really an extension of
the slide you have up here--
this tension between
male expertise and so
at the perception of
female incompetence.
It reminds me of practices
around childbirth
when midwives were saying women
should give birth on their fronts
and men are saying, no, no, women
should give birth on their backs.
[inaudible].
So specifically what are
the specific criticisms?
Like is it women don't
follow receipts, or...?
What is the incompetence?
>> Danille Christensen: I
think really that flexibility
and variation is a big one,
especially when it comes to things
like canning because one
thing that Appert did do
that was innovative is that-- and
also a bit hubris in my own mind--
is that he decided that,
I mean he figured out how
to can every single thing that you
could ever thing of doing, right?
He figured out how much time
you would need to and so
for some vegetables and meats
it was like 4 or 5 hours
of boiling before you could,
before you had pressure canners
that you could raise the
temperature to 240 or 250 degrees.
And so Appert, he decides
that he wants
to can every single thing whereas
in most people's practice, right,
they have this multiplicity of
techniques that meets their goals
and their needs for like the
performance of the product, right?
So, frozen corn tastes better
and lasts better than
canned corn, right?
Or dried apples are better for
fried pies because they don't have
as much moisture and they
don't get soggy, right?
So people like women
in real life are sort
of choosing all these things, but
Appert has rationalized the process
so much that it's like this idea
of the plantation alienation
in some ways, right?
He just likes we're going to apply
this to the, we're going to scale it
up to every single thing regardless
of how good it tastes
or whatever, right?
Could you remind me of
the initial question
because I think I've
gotten off a little bit?
>> Female audience member:
No, no, it's a great job.
Just where is the perception
of the incompetence?
>> Danille Christensen: Oh, right.
So, multiplicity, flexibility
also there's interesting,
so part of that flexibility
is flexibility in the kinds
of technology that you're using.
And so there's in 1935 the same sort
of grumpy bacteriologist who is mad
about other things that women
are doing says, you know,
some people can in wash tubs,
which is I can't imagine how
you get a sanitary product
from a wash tub except that
it's all like boiling, right?
I mean and so this idea of
whereas a lot of canning literature
from earlier in the century is
encouraging like you can do this,
everybody can do this,
this is accessible to you.
All you need is some sort of pan,
something to put in the bottom of it
to keep your bottles
off the metal, right?
And you're ready to go.
So I think just the
open-endedness of it all, right?
It doesn't fit within
that paradigm of control.
>>Male audience member:
Explain to me the tension
between like the rationalization
process
and the folk practices of women.
I wonder if you could kind
of help graph that out for me
or explain the tension between
domestic and whether they kind
of followed along the
same kind of graph.
Because when I think of
canning I think of the opposite
of consumption, right, you know?
Instead of consuming
one is preserving,
when one should be consuming.
I think that's probably
why it's so popular now.
>> Danille Christensen:
Because its production, yeah.
>> Male audience member:
Resistance to consumption.
I wonder if you can kind of help
me graph those things together
or whether that --
>> Danille Christensen: -- so you
mean how has commercial canning
and home canning in
dialogue with each other?
>> Male audience member:
Yeah or whether there is,
whether that same kind of
tension between, you know,
rationalized processes versus
domestic processes also at work
in sort of commercial processes
versus domestic processes?
You know what I'm saying?
Or maybe not?
>> Danille Christensen:
You mean where sort
of domestic processes is
less rationalized relatively
speaking than?
>>Male audience memebr Yes.
>> Danille Christensen: Yeah,
I mean it definitely
happened on smaller scales.
Although there are some people who
are doing lots of quantity canning.
The-- one of the reasons that
people thought Appert was
so revolutionary actually is that
he devised a plan for scaling
up like this is, this
is how I did it
and this is how we can build
a bigger apparatus and do it
so that we can sell it, right?
So that's one of the
things that happened.
I would say that domestic sciences
and also sort of the threat
of botulism has sort of taken
a lot of the flexibility
out of home canning
procedures now, right?
Because when people
move to different areas
of the country they're using
maybe food stuff that are not as,
you know, tomatoes aren't as acidic
as they used to be or there are lots
of sort of variables that happen
now that require this sort
of blanket everybody do the same
thing so that everybody is covered
and we're not going to have
any leeway because there's
so many variables now
that have changed
that people can't necessarily rely
on traditional methods anymore.
So I don't know if I
answered your question but.
>> Yeah.
>> Nancy Groce: One more question.
>> Danille Christensen: Yeah.
Go ahead.
>> Female audience
member: Thank you so much.
I didn't get to the beginning
of your presentation.
I'm wondering if you have covered
the practices in Eastern Europe?
>> Danille Christensen: I'm focusing
on the United States in context,
yeah, but I would be
curious to know I know
that Eastern Europe has
traditionally had a lot of pickling.
And I would be interested to know
if there is a strong non-sugar,
non-salt, non-vinegar
based practice as well.
>>Female audience member: Yeah,
and I have a couple of comments ...
[ Inaudible ]
You were talking about
botulism and doing things in ...
[ Inaudible ]
to justify ...
started doing it less because
of the fear of botulism.
Have you
[ Inaudible ]
to the economic situation,
to lack of social......
[ Inaudible ]
>>Danille Christensen:
Yeah, I think, you know,
a lot of people don't know that
the things that people process
at home most of the time nowadays--
jams, jellies, pickles, those, --
botulism is not really an issue
because you've got those added
preservatives already built in,
right?
By definitely in that sort
of 80s and 90s the canning,
the canning industry people
were really like aware of all
of these sort of social factors that
were also affecting those practice
and yet I think it's easy for people
to say," oh, I'm afraid of doing
that because I don't
want to do it wrong."
It's an easy out for not having
to sort of being involved
in the practice especially if other
people think you should be doing it,
right?
>> Nancy Groce: I want
to thank you so much.
I want to thank Danille
Christensen for coming and you all
for coming and for a great talk.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.